[Music]
I'm so good thanks I am late happy nice
thank you you too thank you
new dress yes it is hot you know what
just happened
[Music]
let's get you past Britain Peter Parker
here to pick up a passport please
may toothpaste pack your suit I just
want to go on my trip with my friends
Europe doesn't really need it friendly
neighborhood spider
[Music]
you look really pretty therefore I have
value no sorry I miss you you look
pretty too I just played some time with
NZ I want you to do my first solo I just
finished my some coffee so nice to
finally meet you
in spite of man
your Nick Fury put some clothes on let's
go for a ride is she gonna be okay like
that might want to turn him over so he
doesn't swallow his tongue
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
awesome
get gifts Parker what a job to do
are you going to step up or not
you're all alone your friends are in
trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's no spider-man
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighbor it has a
dope suit and I really respect him
sup dickwad
[Music]